pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
ampoule la clôture puisque cela fait
cinq jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à
faire à une obstruction je voudrais dire
que l'obstruction c'est la négation du
rôle du Parlement bien sûr le rôle du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été élu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement
d'autodésissement du Parlement vous
allez refuser puisque on va intrins
d'escargot de voir et de voter sur
l'ensemble du texte par exemple sur les
petites retraites par exemple sur
l'usure professionnelle par exemple sur
le handicap au travail et bien nous nous
voulons je crois que choisir de ne pas
voter c'est choisir de ne pas peser
méfiez-vous bien que l'obstruction ne
mène pas à alimenter l'anti
parlementarisme parce que les Français
vont constater qu'à force de discuter le
Parlement ne sert à rien oui je
l'affirme je l'affirme l'obstruction est
au Parlement ce qu'une désertion est un
soldat la négation même de sa mission
[Musique]